Good morning John! I can already hear the music building up beneath me so I should probably just
stop talking. This song is about quarks, I wrote it, it's called "Strange Charm".
[singing] A Quark is a fundamental constituent of matter
Observed in 1968 through deep elastic scatter
We found that protons aren't as simple as we thought
We thought they were solid particles but they are not
Protons in fact are made up of 3 separate pieces
It just gets more confusing as our knowledge increases
But that is what a quark is, it's a piece of a proton
And they also make up other things including the neutron
Oh up down strange charm top bottom, if you don't know what a quark is, it don't matter you still got 'em
And with leptons and bosons unless something's amiss
They make up everything that we can see and that we know exists.
Things made up of quarks including protons and neutrons
are composite particles that physicists call hadrons
many types of hadrons are theoretically described
but most exist for only very brief amounts of time
quarks have electric charge, color charge mass and spin
and having color charge means they exist solely
inside of other kinds of particles and cannot exist alone
which is why quarks have never been studied on their own
up down strange charm top bottom. If you don't know what a quark is it don't matter, you still got 'em
and with leptons and bosons unless something's amiss
they make up everything that we can see and that we know exists
quarks can join together in two different ways
baryons and mesons but most instantly decay
if a particle has three quarks then it's a baryon
and if there's one quark and an anti-quark then it is a meson
these tiny bits of matter are part of almost everything
and there is no unified theory to make it less confusing
but the fact that we've identified that they exist at all
is so goddamn remarkable that I just sit in awe
oh, up down strange charm top bottom if you don't know what a quark is it don't matter you still got 'em
and with leptons and bosons unless sonething's amiss
they make up everything that we can see and that we know exists.
I like that song. That's a good song. I hope that you all enjoyed it too,
and you can listen to it anytime by going to dft.ba/quarks
And that's possible because my friend Sam and my friend Allan worked their butts off to create dft.ba,
a url shortening service that reminds you and all the people that you tweet to... to not forget to be awesome.
So, yes, you can have your own dft.ba urls right now, all you have to do is go to dft.ba.
It's very exciting!
It's just one more way that nerdfighteria is taking over the internet.
John, don't forget to be awesome, and I will see you on Friday.